je suis dans le xviie arrondissement de
paris je vais rencontrer isadora elle
est étudiante en deuxième année de
licence d'histoire-géographie l'année
2020 l'année qu'au vite comme on
l'appelle a parfois été éprouvante pour
les étudiants et vous allez voir que
l'année 2000 21 l'est tout autant
bonjour isadora bonjour installe merci
beaucoup de répondre à nos questions
alors vous avez et étudiante en histoire
géo et qu'est ce que c'est d'être
étudiant en france aujourd'hui en 2021
et bien c'est tout à fait particulier je
pense que c'est assez même extrême dans
l'histoire étant donné que c'est très
difficile et on essaie de s'en sortir
comme on peut et de réussir nos études
alors justement donc on sort d'une année
compliquée 2020 c'est elle que vite
c'est le confinement vous vous étiez en
première année comment est ce que vous
avez vécu cette année ça a été donc au
monde tout à fait particulier que je
découvrais c'est à dire le monde
universitaire je sortais du secondaire
avec un bac qu'ovide donc c'est à dire
un bac en contrôle continu
et une mise en confinement dès février
mars avec
et une communication sur les aide pas
assez divulgué donc j'ai dû vraiment
beaucoup cherché
il y en a eu quand même certaines merci
à eux merci à la solidarité étudiante
qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti pendant
cette année qui a été particulière à un
abandon total du gouvernement j'ai
ressenti un abandon total du
gouvernement ça c'est indubitable c'est
clairement
nous laisser nous débrouiller dans un
marché professionnel qui a été
complètement les et qui a été
complètement
mis sous cloche à cause du code idée on
comprend pourquoi évidemment mais
derrière de n'avoir aucun parachute
vis-à-vis de cette fin crise énorme
économique qui a secoué tout le monde
entier j'ai la chance d'avoir au moins
une bourse c'est à dire
570 euros par mois avec 170 euros plus
des appels est ce que vous arrivez
aujourd'hui à
à boucler vos fins de mois à payer votre
loyer
tout juste oui tout juste oui oui tout
juste jean piat du système d à bas le
système de bien sûr je vous montrerai
les astuces vous nous montrez bien sûr
donc il adorait ont parlé des suisses
système d'aidé étudiants comment vous
par exemple est ce que vous vous
débrouillez pour vous alimenter
correctement
alors pour je sais que pour
l'alimentation pour tous qui est sorti
pour tout ce qui est des dépenses en
dehors des frais fixes que j'ai à payer
j'ai 240 euros
240 euros vraiment pour tout faire
240 euros pour tout faire quand on veut
quand on est jeune qu'on veut sortir un
petit peu quand on veut se nourrir c'est
quoi c'est le parcours du combattant
absolument absolument c'est trouver des
stratagèmes au quotidien pour payer moi
mais autre plan b en plus donc j'ai jeu
à travers facebook ou les réseaux
sociaux ou même dehors quand je me
balade
repère rapidement des bouquins qui
quitteraient les bouquins qu'on voit là
ça c'est des bouquins que vous avez
voilà c'est ça que j'ai enfin trouvé
soit dehors soit des bouquins vraiment
de facebook vraiment de tout et
n'importe quoi
vraiment qui permettent ensuite à d'être
revendus et de d'avoir un petit
complément de revenu
c'est pas grand chose mais c'est quand
même là c'est des petits revenus donc
vous pouvez pas vous passer aujourd'hui
c'est toujours du plus oui c'est
toujours du plus qui permet de temps en
temps un peu sortir quand même de faire
comme les autres de aller dans un bar à
paris tout de la vie vraiment énorme
d'ailleurs je me demande pourquoi
justement pour les étudiants pour les
revenus les bourses donc pourquoi enfin
une idée aurait été d'infléchir sa sur
le coût de la vie en fonction de
l'espace géographique qu'occupe
l'étudiant vous êtes en 2e année
aujourd'hui est ce que vous aviez c'est
ce que vous aviez imaginé la vie
étudiante parce que vous étiez au lycée
je l'imaginais vraiment quelque chose de
ou tout allait être simple tout allait
être resplendissante avec beaucoup
d'échangés intellectuels où on allait
pouvoir se rencontrer entre les
disciplines pouvoir échanger créer des
utopies et au final on se retrouve
depuis notre studio d'étudiant pour ceux
qui ont la chance d'avoir un studio a
effectivement je m'attendais pas à faire
un face-à-face permanent avec mon
ordinateur pour l'avenir et ce que
globalement vous dit vous vous êtes
plutôt confiante en l'avenir ou plutôt
méfiante comment est-ce que vous comment
est-ce que vous abordez les choses
aujourd'hui je suis tout à fait très
inquiète très inquiète avec un diplôme
universitaire remontant du coc vide je
suis persuadé que des employeurs sur la
marché de l'emploi quand ils verront
deux jeunes avec un
une licence non période de vide et une
période de vide va forcément préféré
l'étudiant n'ont pas l'air trop vite car
il saura qu'il a été formé bon aux
minima correctement nous on a les
programmes ont été raccourcies donc
énormément de cours ont été mis à
distance des professeurs qui arrive pas
avec forcément l'informatique à se
débrouiller ou quoi des polycopiés
balancer comme ça d c'est ça aujourd'hui
les études et c'est vraiment un
désavantage énorme qu'on a